[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7 8 débat dans la nuit du 24
au 25 février dernier 900 mètres cubes
de pétrole brut se sont déversés dans la
nature
suite à la rupture d'un pipeline qui
relie le havre à grandpuits en seine et
marne
l incident s'est produit dans le secteur
de touiller de boissy sans avoir
notamment dans les yvelines
l as et a été rapidement colmatée mais
une zone de 8 hectares a été touchée par
la pollution est l'évacuation et le
remplacement des terres salées vont
prendre plusieurs mois
l quelles vont être les conséquences
pour notre département nous allons
tenter et d'y répondre ce soir avec nos
invités et david itié bonsoir elle vous
êtes co secrétaire régional europe
ecologie/les verts en ile de france et
vous avez notamment suivi de près cet
incident tout comme marc rémond bonsoir
vous êtes le président de france nature
environnement dans le département 78 toi
là c'est ce que j'allais ajouter dans le
département est des yvelines merci en
tout cas tous les deux est d'être
présent ce soir alors juste avant de
poursuivre je tenais juste à vous
informer que total en avaient été
conviés à ce débat l'invitation a été
décliné car je cite toutes les personnes
sont mobilisées sur le chantier de
nettoyage et de remédiation du pipeline
alors pour l'instant l'origine de cette
fuite de cette fuite est toujours
inconnue depuis plusieurs semaines les
opérations de nettoyage et de
dépollution se poursuivent et nicolas
landry de la rédaction de tv 78 c'est
justement rendu sur ce chantier
le 12 le 12 mars dernier je vous propose
de voir tout de suite un extrait de son
reportage ils sont installés ici pour
plusieurs mois les équipes de
dépollution sont à pied d'oeuvre pour
nettoyer le lieu de l'incident plusieurs
champs agricoles ont été touchés par
l'écoulement des 900 mètres cubes de
pétrole derrière nous nous avons des
hydrocarbures sont en train de pomper
les arrivées hydrocarbures qui sont
collectés par les drones et dans les
piscines que nous avons creusé dans des
tranchées avec la phase de nettoyage les
équipes se penche aussi sur le pipe line
après avoir extrait mis sous scellés
pour l'anc est le morceau à l'origine de
la fuite
la réparation a commencé ainsi que la
dépollution des terres laissant là où
ceux qui sont près de la fuite se sont
pollués c'est là bas qu'on va devoir
excavés c'est à dire retirer les terres
et les déposer à côté sur un liner et
les envoyer ensuite en dépollution
alors le chantier doit durer encore
plusieurs mois on parle jusqu'au mois de
novembre
est-ce que selon vous les mesures prises
par les autorités et par total sont
suffisamment adapté à cette situation
écoutez tout d'abord un petit point
sémantique vous avez lancé le sujet en
parlant d'un incident est de 8 hectares
de champs qui sont touchés pour nous que
le gist il s'agit bien plus que d'un
incident c'est un véritable accident
pour les populations locales c'est
dramatique pour les agriculteurs qui
exploitent ces terres ça signifie tout
simplement la perte de leur outil de
travail donc il s'agit beaucoup plus que
d'un incident et puis la surface qui est
touchée se limite pas évidemment aux
huit hectares de terres qui sont
mitoyennes directement de la fuite qui a
été provoqué par cette rupture de
l'oléoduc
mais c'est bien tout le bassin versant
qui est touchée on a retrouvé des
oiseaux mazoutés
c'est bien ici une marée noire
campagnarde à laquelle on assiste donc
il faut surtout ne pas tomber dans la
sémantique de total qui parle
d'incidents qui parle de fuite
non il s'agit bien d'une marée noire
locale en plein milieu des des yvelines
après pour répondre à votre question est
ce que toutes les mesures ont été prises
on aimerait bien le savoir vous savez
nous nous sommes rendus avec une petite
délégation d'élus écologistes on avait
pu lire çà tout riquet président du
groupe écologiste conseil régional marie
toussaint également qui est à l'origine
de la pétition la sphère du siècle qu'a
recueilli plus de deux millions de
signatures et qui lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique en mobilisant les
citoyens et citoyennes comme rarement on
s'est rendu sur le site
justement pour savoir si total mettait
tout en oeuvre pour pour régler le
problème et on a été très surpris
on a été très surpris de ne pas pouvoir
accéder librement au site la route est
barrée des des deux côtés et pas
uniquement pour des raisons de sécurité
manifestement parce que ces barres est
très en amont et 13 en aval du chantier
et donc ça nous alerte sur la cacher en
tout cas quand on prend de telles
mesures on nous a également interdit de
filmer la la zone au vu du ciel juste au
dessus de 2 du lieu de l'accident donc
c'est ça donne effectivement très peu
confiance dans ce que total peut mettre
peut mettre en oeuvre quand il a à
cacher si s'ils ne veulent pas comme
cela laisser accéder librement aussi
donc nous ce qu'on demande avant tout
c'est que total ne soit pas le seul à
mesurer l'ampleur des dégâts a estimé
les réparations nécessaires et à
réaliser un suivi ensuite des pollutions
qui vont persister non pas pendant
quelques mois la durée du chantier mais
pendant des années et donc les
réunion qui sont actuellement organisées
régulièrement le ciel vie voilà doit
aussi associé naturellement les
associations des experts indépendants et
les habitants et habitantes de la zone
voilà ce que nous ce que nous demandons
est bien entendu des élus des élus du
territoire en toute transparence et en
toute indépendance il n'est pas possible
que soit totale qui aujourd'hui soit à
l'origine de l'accident et qui aussi
pilote les réparations et le suivi des
réparations ou en assumer les
conséquences
financer cette vision le fait que total
en fête soit totale qui pilotent
justement un signe enfin bon on va dire
c'est on peut pas être juge et partie et
puis nous ce qui nous gêne
essentiellement si vous dites c'est que
quand nous posons des questions qui sont
censés on va dire de bon sens puisque
nous ne sommes pas nés ce père qui ne
sont pas des spéciales comme disait
moribond d'abord quelques airs et qui la
quantité de tubes de combustible qui
était qui s'est écoulée quelle a été la
réactivité
à partir de quel moment qui totalisera
tir est intervenu
comment ont été pris en compte les
premiers comme on dit rage
les premières informations qui ont été
données notamment par un de nos
adhérents qui habite cannes l'issue si
je puis dire quoi et qui est dédié
dimanche soir à signaler a ressenti des
gens qui se passait des choses est que
le lundi matin alors lille a appelé les
services ou les pompiers sont intervenus
et fatale après moi donc je vous rejoins
en disant on ne peut pas considérer
normal que une sauce talent soit juge et
partie alors maintenant il est clair que
la préfecture le préfet après un bond
arrêté dans lequel il y bien ce que
total va devoir faire et ce qui va être
fait pour obtenir ou aller à la vérité
seulement ce qui nous gêne là encore
c'est que quand nous posons de nouveau
des questions précises aux personnes
présentes dans les réunions on ne vit
pas ses couverts par le secret de
l'instruction
donc si vous voulez monsieur le préfet a
dit ça va se faire en toute transparence
et puis on définit si le tout comme vous
bat déjà quand on veut aller sur le
chantier on est très loin il faut
demander des autorisations et les
associations ne se sont pas encore
réunis sur le chantier
car nous allons le faire bientôt pour
savoir où nous en sommes donc un petit
peu d'avancé par rapport à l'or est ce
que selon vous ces incidents accidents
comme vous dit peut être la conséquence
d'un manque d'entretien ne s'est pas eu
de ce pacte en l'occurrence puisqu'il y
avait bien un précédent notamment en
2014 sur ce même place et effectivement
on peut se poser la question mais plus
fondamentalement nous pensons que cet
accident il est le reflet d'un système
qui a été mis en place
donc dans les années 60 ce type-là ni là
il ya à peu près une cinquantaine
d'années à une époque où on se pose est
absolument pas les questions de
dépendance énergétique d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre des effets de la
pollution sur la santé comme on se les
posent actuellement et il est le
révélateur d'une politique de total qui
continue à miser sur le tout pétrole et
qui ne cherche absolument pas à en
sortir et ce type d'incident sur des
infrastructures qui sont venus parce
qu'elles sont et hérité d'un système
énergétique qui est ancien il faut
absolument sortir et nous ce qu'on
demande maintenant à total c'est de
profiter de cette démonstration de la
vétusté de ses infrastructures et de son
système pour absolument engager une
vraie modification de ces politiques
énergie et employés que total
aujourd'hui consacre encore plusieurs
milliards par an à prospecter de
nouveaux forages pour à nouveau aller
chercher du pétrole qui serait beaucoup
mieux dans le sous-sol faut absolument
que total arrêtent d'aller prospecter de
nouveaux gisements et qu'il essaye d'en
d'extraire de nouveau du pétrole et
qu'il s'engage vraiment dans une
transition énergétique voilà ce que
révèle cet incident cet accident par
dons envoyés de la sémantique revient
revient vite est le point-clé il est là
cet accident qui s'est produit il est le
révélateur d'un système énergétique qui
est toujours portée par total qui est
toujours soutenu par les autorités
françaises par l'état et dont il faut
absolument sortir qu'au convenant tout
de même que l'on va pas sortir de cette
dépendance énergétique par rapport aux
énergies fossiles par un coup de
baguette magique
il va y avoir encore pendant des
décennies probablement besoin de pétrole
là où on en a besoin et où les les
comment dirais-je et pai plane achemine
le pétrole
ce qu'il faudrait c'est vu c'est que à
cette occasion comme vous le disiez on
repense nos modèles certes mais que
surtout on fasse le nécessaire pour que
ça ne se reproduise pas et lorsque vous
dites est ce que vous pensez que c'est
le système enfin le peuple ami et et
vitus quelque chose comme ça ça ce sont
des réponses que nous attendons
maintenant les réponses là ne nous
satisferons pas si on ne nous dit pas on
va faire tout ce que l'on peut pour que
ça ne se reproduise pas ce que nous
souhaiterions tout de même et en tant
que citoyen c'est qu'effectivement dans
cette affaire l'administration total et
les associations et les habitants du
coin est une démarche gagnante gagnante
et c'est ce que nous espérons sachant
que au niveau de mairie par exemple il y
à un poste électrique qui est maintenant
une référence grâce au travail de rte et
des associations
voilà en fait on souhaite une démarche
si vous voulez loyal
alors mercredi 27 février le miz de la
transition écologique françois de rugy
s'est rendu justement à auteuil il a
notamment déclaré que l'état serait
ferme avec total deux semaines plus tard
et il dans le même état d'esprit c'est
ce que lui a demandé où il frida richy
rédacteur en chef de tv 78 dans
l'émission territoire d'infos sur public
sénat jeudi dernier l'émission dont tv
78 et partenaires on regarde on écoute
françois de rugy comment pouvez vous
assurer qu'il y aura une transparence
complète sur les opérations menées par
total alors sur la transparence je les
fait en me rendant sur place dès le
lendemain de cet accident qui montrent
en effet que l'utilisation par ailleurs
des hydrocarbures elle elle présente des
dangers un au delà de présenter le
problème de l'effet de serre elle
présente des dangers pour notre
environnement à tout moment où à la
terre comme en mer
par ailleurs j'ai demandé à ce que total
et ce sera fait payent tous les travaux
donc là les images que nous avons vues
elles sont spectaculaires et très
spectaculaire puisque ça veut dire
concrètement il faut qu'on dise on est
en train de ramasser la terre sur sans
doute plus d'un mètre d'épaisseur sur
des hectares et des hectares donc ce
sont des tonnes et des tonnes de terre
qu'il faut ramasser qu'il va falloir
traiter ensuite car il n'est pas
question de remettre de la terre
évidemment polluer sans doute d'ailleurs
que ce sera une autre terre qui sera
remise la avec les agriculteurs en un
chantier extrêmement important tout sera
payée par total par ailleurs nous
demandons à ce qu'il y ait également des
inspections renforcées sur tout le
réseau des pailles plagne en france car
il y en a évidemment dans beaucoup de
régions pour alimenter les raffineries
pour alimenter les dépôts de carburant
et ce travail est en cours
une réaction marc rémond parce que je
viens de dire très bien mais je ne sais
pas ce que dit monsieur de rugy c'est
c'est la même chose que ce que nous
avons entendu de monsieur le préfet brot
à savoir la transparence
or pour l'instant c'est opaque c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire puisque toutes
nos questions oui on nous dit c'est le
secret de l'instruction
ça ne peut pas satisfaire les
populations c'est ou bien on est en
transparence et et on y est on donne des
informations
on va pas en faire un mauvais usage on
en fera un mauvais usage s'ils ont un
sentiment qu'on nous dit rien voilà
meetic a cependant fait des procès
d'intention et de part et d'autre des
visites est juste une réaction par
rapport aux propos de françois de rugy
oui mais je rejoins à ce que ce que dit
le représentant de france nature
environnement françois de rugy me dit la
transparence elle est assurée parce que
je me suis rendu sur place
non c'est absolument pas ça que les
habitants les habitantes et puis
l'ensemble des personnes concernées sur
le territoire attendent c'est pas c'est
pas un ministre qui va nous assurer la
transparence parce qu'il est allé se
promener sur le site
évidemment donc on attend je rappelle ce
que ce qui a déjà été dit que total
donne toutes les informations qu'on lui
pose les questions que les habitants et
habitantes les associations et les élus
soient pleinement associées à l'ensemble
des démarches de dépollution du site là
où françois de rugy a raison c'est quand
il rappelle la dangerosité des
hydrocarbures et ça rejoint ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure qu'il faut
absolument qu'une entreprise comme total
qui est régulièrement
l'auteur de catastrophe écologique de se
pose des questions sur sa politique et
son avenir de celles africaines sur ces
axes structurants naturellement mais
également sur l'ensemble de sa politique
de développement elle ne peut pas
continuer à tout miser sur le pétrole
vous le disiez évidemment on va pas
sortir du pétrole d'un claquement de
doigts ça fait 40 ans qu'on aurait dû
imaginer la transition énergétique
ça n'a pas été fait il est temps
désormais de se poser ces questions et
total aujourd'hui n'en prend pas le
chemin donc nous l'invitons total à se
poser ces questions-là
à l'occasion de ces accidents qu'ils
produisent régulièrement on peut pas
avoir une grande entreprise comme total
aussi riche aussi puissante qui est le
dix-neuvième pollueur mondial en termes
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
continue comme si de rien n'était à
avoir des politiques d'extraction et de
transport de produits aussi dangereux
sans rien faire pour diminuer ses
activités polluantes et dangereuses
après cet accident est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter pour la biodiversité
bien sûr bien sûr alors là il faut
s'inquiéter pour tout ce qui peut être
impacté et moi je lirai commencement par
nous inquiéter pour la population
et après on va s'occuper de la flore de
la faune et du res
enfin
population elle est la façon et j'ai
voulu les voilà on nous dit également
que healy a aujourd'hui semble-t-il 400
mètres cubes durée que de récupérer car
nous sommes les 500 autres sont actives
où ils sont ils moi c'est ça la question
on en a récupéré 400 bons soit mais les
500 autres et en combien de temps cela
va être restituée dans le milieu voilà
une bonne question de sombrer dans la
jeu on est en avoir une réponse
est ce que vous savez si la faune a été
touchée parce que la préfecture
communique des chiffres en disant que la
mortalité animale est jugé plutôt faible
est ce que vous avez d'autres
informations justement sur toujours en
trop par rapport aux nappes phréatiques
est ce que vous savez si elles ont été
touchées parce que là encore la
préfecture se veut rassurante en disant
voilà que la nappe phréatique n'a pas
été touchée mais est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir justement j'aimerais que j'ai en
mémoire la lui a quitté pas pu toucher
juste une petite précision le l'accident
il a eu lieu à quelques centaines de
mètres de la limite externe de la zone
de captage sur la nappe qui est juste en
dessous donc la nappe phréatique
j'imagine difficilement que lé pas été
touchés ou en tout cas à minima il faut
absolument faire un suivi extrêmement
précis et rigoureux et nous allons les
arrêter et ne pas hésiter à avertir la
population
au moindre problème détecté dans le nord
je veux dire dans le dos
et puis la pollution
comme je disais tout à l'heure elle va
pas se limiter aux sites c'est
l'ensemble du bassin versant qui qui va
être touchée peut-être même jusqu'aux
berges aux berges de seine
si on a 500 mètres cubes d'hydrocarbures
dont on ne sait pas actuellement où ils
sont ça veut dire qu'ils se sont d'ores
et déjà dispersé c'est quand même 500
millions de litres de pétrole brut donc
oui l'impact sur l'environnement il est
là on a juste en aval du site de la
catastrophe une zone il en est classé
zone naturelle un marais catherine rich
juste au dessus alors il allait en dame
en l'isle et il est moins directement
concernés par les pollutions puisqu
elles ont tendance à descendre sur les
bassins versants
mais on a des zones naturelles qui
jouent des rôles de réservoirs de
biodiversité qui roulait qui jouaient
des rôles de d'épuration des eaux des
eaux fluviales extrêmement importants et
ces zones là elles sont évidemment
touché quand on a un million de mètres
cubes d'hydrocarbures qui qui se déverse
comme ça dans la nature de la panne
n'est pas un débardeur millions de
litres ces mois là dans les chiffres
c'est quelque chose auquel j'ai déjà
sensible 1 millions dans les crédits
decoded rocard de mandat dans la nature
naturellement les impacts
environnementaux ils sont très
importants et ce qui est aussi important
à souligner c'est que quand on a une
catastrophe comme comme celle ci souvent
on essaye de la chiffrer et je pense que
c'est une erreur
on peut pas donner un prix à la nature
on peut pas donner un prix à la
destruction occasionnés par une telle
catastrophe et la seule chose que peut
faire total aujourd'hui cedar deniz et
les pertes économiques mais les pertes
sur la biodiversité l'environnement
elles sont irrémédiables surtout que bon
évaluer les préjudices pour les uns et
les autres
ça fait gérer assez courant si un
travail de 510 assureur on va dire et on
va pas remettre ce problème en question
et la manière dont ces traités mais moi
j'insiste bien ce que nous souhaitons
nous c'est un comprendre ce qui s'est
passé pour éviter que ça se reproduise 1
et est ensuite que nous puissions
participer à un comité de suivi
car pour l'instant l'idée avait été
évoquée me semble-t-il est en fin de
compte
aujourd'hui on est libre on attendait
presque circulez ya rien à voir
il faut nous faire confiance certes on
va on veut bien faire confiance aussi
bien être total que au service de l'état
qui sont très compétents est compétent
peut-être pas insuffisant en nombre
d'ailleurs poursuit ce genre d'événement
ou
les prévoir mais nous on en sait quelque
chose aussi est en tout cas on a droit à
la vérité et à l'information
la prochaine réunion n'a d'ailleurs lieu
le 27 mars à vic j'imagine que vous y
participeraient oui voici david jutier
j'espère qu'on aura des représentants
des élus
moi je serais pas je serai pas convié
mais j'invite effectivement la
préfecture a invité des élus régionaux
de tous les groupes puisque c'est un
incident qui a un accident qui a des
répercussions sur l'ensemble de la
région et sur le les mesures qui sont à
mettre en oeuvre totale annonce une
inspection de l'ensemble de ses
infrastructures
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est que
l'inspection de ses infrastructures
soient pas uniquement conduite par total
il faut absolument un audit de
l'ensemble des oléoducs du territoire
territoire national et même européen
puisque les oléo dit que non pas de
frontières l'émission touche bientôt à
sa fin une minute chacun pourra pour
conclure ou comment savez-vous david
jutier oui je vais revenir sur sur ce
que je disais tout à l'heure que cet
accident
il est le reflet d'un système qui a été
mis en place après après la deuxième
guerre mondiale qui est complètement
vétuste aujourd'hui à peu près aussi
vétuste que les oléoducs de de total et
que une multinationale qui brassent des
milliards qui est spécialisée dans
l'évasion fiscale devrait se spécialiser
dans la transition énergétique c'est
urgent moi j'aimerais que les
associations soient considérés comme des
intérieurs qui les interlocuteurs
valables logique citoyens et que nous
puissions ont joué le rôle que l'on nous
demande en permanence du jouet à savoir
d'être responsable
on peut pas être responsable si on ne
sait pas et moins de rétention
d'information ce que vous semblez dire
et je n'ai pas utilisé ce mot parce que
c'est ça voudrait dire que je fais un
procès d'intention peut-être le ferons
nous un moment quand ce sera certain que
effectivement on ne nous dit pas que tu
es dans nos bons moments merci en tout
cas à tous les deux d'avoir été à
présent ce soir on se retrouve
évidemment mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat
[Musique]